What is your opinion on taking low dose naltrexel?
So naltrexel was initially introduced into the market.
It's a drug.
It's a drug at 50 milligrams to help get people off of more feed addiction.
So I think you're talking about low dose naltrexel.
You're starting off at 1.5 milligrams.
Move the three milligrams and move to 4.5 milligrams.
So low dose naltrexel is an immune modulator.
That's really how it works.
So is low dose naltrexel good for cancer as an off label drug for cancer?
I have not found it to be all that useful for cancer.
I've not seen any studies.
Maybe I haven't looked lately for cancer.
I found it to be extremely helpful for autoimmune patients because it could help.
So with an autoimmune condition, you want to call immune response.
So immune regulation is helpful.
So all the end stimulates what's called T-reg production.
So T-regs are a type of T cell subset called T-regulator cells that can help calm the immune response in somebody who has a hyperimmune reaction with an autoimmune disease.
Now, there are some people that say that it can be a T-regulator.
It can help bring up somebody's immune response if it's super suppressed.
So in that case, I would say that it would be helpful.
So I would say low dose naltrexel will be helpful.
If somebody's voice or chemo and their white blood cell felt is extremely suppressed and they're struggling with immune suppression.
It can help bring that up.
It's not going to be an immune stimulant where it's going to help kill cancer.
But it can help bring up a suppressed immune response.
So in that case, I would say it's worth a try.
But really there's not a whole lot of side effects from taking it.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with giving a try.